today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink ascom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com I got a really interesting
email from a viewer over the weekend who
sent me a link to a George Packer
article in the Atlantic and the article
is called we are living in a failed
state and what this viewer wants me to
consider which I'm going to do today is
instead of analyzing the micro failures
of Trump on coronavirus so instead of
talking about not enough testing Trump
didn't take it seriously the Orwellian
press briefings all of that stuff that
would be like a micro analysis of the
failure from this particular
administration on coronavirus the viewer
suggests that that izu mout and consider
whether the mishandling of coronavirus
by Trump is actually a sign of a much
broader issue which is the United States
being a failed state and we just didn't
notice until we had a real crisis like
coronavirus as George Packer says in the
Atlantic the coronavirus didn't break
America it revealed what was already
broken so I want to think about this and
and really examine whether there may be
something to it now if we come out with
the answer that the u.s. is a failed
state it does not absolve Donald Trump
of responsibility but it would be a
different analysis for us to do so let's
start with what is a failed state what
does that mean a state that has failed
typically to find a failed state is a
political body that has disintegrated to
a point where basic conditions and
responsibilities of a sovereign
government no law
longer function properly the other side
of it is a state can also fail if the
government loses legitimacy even if it
is performing some of those functions
properly you might remember last week in
my segment Donald Trump has turned me
into a prepper I pointed out that I've
been doing more prepping as the term is
because of the realization I came to
that people truly are ignorant enough in
this country to elect someone like
Donald Trump where you cannot trust that
government officials will be competent
enough ethical enough and pathetic
enough to handle just even the basics
during a situation like this global
pandemic we're dealing with that would
be part of a failed state it is a
characteristic of a failed state now
let's think of some examples usually
when we think of examples of failed
States from our admittedly Western point
of view we think of places like Liberia
and Eritrea in Africa where you see
combinations of no infrastructure I mean
you know some there's no clean water no
sewage systems in some cases to complete
dictatorial rule both can be elements of
failed States we might think of North
Korea to go to a different part of the
world certainly I think that one makes
sense to a lot of people Syria is a very
different situation than Liberia North
Korea and Eritrea but Syria is often
considered a failed state although maybe
you would see some revolutionary
leftists who disagree Iraq often is
considered a failed state although we
can't ignore that we the United States
through foreign policy through the first
and second world uh Gulf Wars we've
played a big role in getting Iraq to its
current state if we determine it's
failed we certainly bear some
responsibility for that totally
different example Zimbabwe Zimbabwe over
the last couple of decades is often
called a failed state Somalia others
okay so if we apply the same exact
standard that we might look at in
Eritrea or North Korea to the u.s. the
u.s. is not a failed state by that
standard but what I suggest we do is
let's step back a little bit from our
sort of Western centric point of view
can we argue that coronavirus has
exposed the failings of the United
States here are the elements that George
Packer points to which again he says
these aren't new under Donald Trump but
they have been exposed by coronavirus
not created by coronavirus exposed by it
I'll include some of George Packers
examples from the article which you
should read and some of mine as well
okay a corrupt political class we knew
about cronyism nepotism oligopoly etc in
the United States before coronavirus but
coronavirus has really exposed it in an
acute way total cronyism complete
nepotism the Jared Kushner Fiasco oleg
ah Polly and the handing of these very
lucrative contracts to companies that
Trump likes that Trump has determined
these are the people that are going to
get these contracts we have it but it's
dressed up with some of the window
dressings of democratic neoliberalism
but we have a corrupt political class
here in the United States and certainly
coronavirus has exposed it one to two
months of distraction from dealing with
the virus with everything from lies
bragging scapegoating everyone from
China to Democrats that is an element of
a failed state
when blown up to a greater degree we've
seen the conspiracy theories and the
promotion of miracle cures you often see
that in these despotic countries that
are often by Western standards
considered failed States we've seen
everything from Bill Gates vaccine
conspiracy theories to trump personally
promoting the supposed miracle cure of
hydroxychloroquine four weeks after then
no longer mentioning it again until last
night during his town hall he brought it
back which will talk about endless
boasting about how many ventilators and
masks and other PPE they were getting
and making and ordering as we find out
thanks to good reporting that we were
sending PPE to places like Thailand at
the same time that Trump officials were
calling Thailand saying hey
we need PPE can you send it to us wait a
second you're sending us PPE it's like a
who's on first skit we covered that a
few weeks ago a degree of breakdown
we've seen that led to individuals
having to print masks with their 3d
printers and kids sewing masks for
health care workers a president who has
dealt with the virus in exclusively
political terms often doing an entire
press briefing as we've seen him do
never talking about the health side of
this fiasco until a reporter forces him
to by asking a question a degree of
cronyism and inequality where we see
during the pandemic nearly 20% of the
country has already lost their jobs but
the super-rich and some corporations are
making a killing profiting from the
virus we see a growing divide in the
country where we have a majority that is
mostly concerned with the virus and
wants to do what doctors say we should
do and public health experts and then on
the other hand you have this small but
very loud minority that is aggressively
protesting to reopen they are clad with
guns and bulletproof vests many of whom
believe the virus is some kind of hoax
or a fake thing it's not literally a
country run by warlords as are many of
the failed States we talked about but if
we adjust our analysis for a Western
democracy as we like to call it you know
the the gun-toting people who are
demanding states be reopened that that's
a that's that's that's a sign of
dystopia to put it lightly so if we go
by the standards that we often apply to
other countries is the u.s. a failed
state no it's not not in the same way
that our countries that lack running
water or transportation or roads that
work or functioning utilities that's not
the the the standard by which we are a
failed state but this is the United
States of America we don't typically
hold ourselves to the standards of Syria
and North Korea and Eritrea we can argue
about whether we should or shouldn't but
we don't left and right typically do not
hold the u.s. to that standard and
in a sense we've been left to figure it
out on our own our own being States
individual states and governors when it
comes to the virus so by our standards
George Packer is right the United States
federal government has dramatically
failed and what George Packer points out
in his really eloquently in his article
and you really should read it is that
all of this stuff has been the case for
a long time one of the richest countries
in the world and yet so many people have
no savings and no health insurance one
of the countries with the best
universities and yet everything from
anti-vaxxer ism to all of the other anti
science nonsense runs rampant in certain
parts of the country and even inside of
government that is a failure there is no
doubt about it for the average person
the state has failed and it's just
becoming much more clear in the context
of coronavirus let me know what you
think I'm curious to hear from you at
the risk of sounding like perpetually
disappointed Republican senator Susan
Collins I have to tell you guys I'm
really disappointed in some of my fellow
Twitter followers former President
George W Bush a war criminal for sure
okay you're hearing me say it right up
at the top George W Bush put out a video
which he narrated calling for unity and
action on coronavirus it's a totally
uncontroversial video from a very
controversial person okay I posted it to
my Twitter page over the week and then I
pointed out when George W Bush sounds
reasonable you know you have incompetent
and impotent leadership this was of
course not me praising george w bush but
i was pointing out that when someone as
horrible as george w bush is able to
just put together a reasonable statement
while our current president is unable to
even sound remotely like a normal person
even one time when talking about the
virus it proves how bad our leadership
is that was the point that I was making
and a ton of people reacted by saying
David you are rehabilitating a war
criminals reputation and of course it's
the opposite it's reminding ourselves
that you know man george w bush was so
bad and he sounds completely normal in
this video because our current president
is off-the-wall bonkers but the best
part of it all is that this was a
completely mild and milquetoast video by
george w bush just calling for political
unity and it completely triggered donald
trump so let's look first at the video
then we'll talk about the trump
component this is a challenging in
solemn time the life of our nation and
world a remorseless invisible enemy
threatens the elderly and vulnerable
among us a disease that can quickly take
breath in life medical professionals are
risking their own health for the health
of others and we're deeply grateful
officials at every level are setting out
the requirements of public health that
protect us all so I think you get it you
can find the full three-minute video
online it's just a call to unity that's
all it is it's completely
uncontroversial and Donald Trump
couldn't take it Donald Trump called out
bush for not supporting him in his
impeachment trial if you can imagine
something more absurd Trump first quotes
Pete hagseth from Fox News of course
saying px that said oh by the way i
apprec--
by spelled be ye oh by the way I
appreciate the message from former
President Bush but where was he during
impeachment calling for putting
partisanship aside and then Trump
himself adds Bush was nowhere to be
found in speaking up against the
greatest hoax in American history
so Trump is not only highly triggered
but he seems to be equating the pandemic
to his own impeachment impeachment of
course a political process which was
completely warranted by the facts and it
was completely partisan now Trump may
see it as Democrats conspired against me
without evidence in impeachment but
there's no analogy to coronavirus did
the corona virus conspire against Trump
now what Trump would argue is he handled
it all perfectly and yet Democrats and I
guess former Republican President Bush
are all conspiring to claim Trump did a
bad job but
there's really no analogy and this you
know his impeachment being like the
virus is an endlessly narcissistic
comment to make but notice the ease with
which George W Bush triggers Donald
Trump merely by saying hey let's not be
horrible partisans let's come together
on this let's protect people let's do
the right thing and Trump sees that as
an attack it says way more about Trump
than it does about Bush now I want to go
back again pointing out that george w
bush put out a normal statement doesn't
mean i'm saying anything positive about
george w bush i'm pointing out that even
george w bush a terrible immoral
president was able to put out a
statement that sounds completely normal
in a time of crisis what it shows us is
how uniquely unhinged trump is it says
nothing good about george w bush some
people just want to see the left eat
itself and even people on the left want
to see that you know pointing out that
biden is better than trump is not
supporting sexual assault pointing out
george w bush is better than Trump is
not rehabilitating the reputation of a
war criminal let's get it together guys
we've got very important things going on
we've got to remove this president we're
dealing with a pandemic there it think
the stakes are too high to be eating
ourselves at this point in time let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman we will take a quick break and we
have so much more coming up for you
today the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blink Asst to
get a sample first just think how much
you can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
accom slash david pakman I've put the
link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are allison Cooke and Jacqueline
Rickman Allison and Jacqueline thank you
so much for your support as you may know
membership is our primary source of
funding members instantly get access to
the world-famous bonus show every single
day an extra show for our members you
also get commercial free audio and video
streams of the entire show and Members
Only newsletter updates from me
sign up at join pakman.com also want to
say thanks to Samuel Johnson who is
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day Samuels been a member for almost
5 years and I so appreciate your support
Samuel thank you so much ok a Donald
Trump had a completely propagandistic
1984 style Town Hall yesterday he took
questions from Americans via video while
sitting at the Lincoln Memorial
yesterday we believed that it was Donald
Trump who had selected the Lincoln
Memorial as the location but then during
this event Donald Trump said oh no you
guys told it fought you guys being Fox
News you guys told us you wanted it at
the Lincoln Memorial the two fox hosts
bret bayer and martha maccallum visibly
confused about wait a second I thought
we were here because you wanted us here
doesn't even matter that's only the tip
of the iceberg my friends because it was
an absolute and complete nightmare now
because we're doing fewer and fewer of
the briefings I do think it's important
to bring you a sense of what the
president is communicating and in
relation to our segment earlier today on
whether the United States is a failed
state of sorts last night's Town Hall
was more than illuminating in that sense
now first of all Donald Trump came in
absolutely shot out of a cannon like he
was on some kind of upper and we've
talked about this before Trump visibly
very sweaty sniffing repeating himself
more than usual clenching his jaw unable
to sit still and you know we know about
these two versions of Trump you've got
upper Trump and then you've got downer
Trump as I like to call them something
very strange seems to contain
with Donald Trump along those lines it's
tough to analyze and we may never know
the full scope of that let's put the
sort of appearance aside and focus on
the content what we can more easily
analyze was the absolutely debased
and abominable things that Donald Trump
said along with the complete and total
lack of truth in almost every single
answer that Donald Trump gave it would
be hard to do a more dishonest townhall
he also barely answered any of the
questions in anything what we would call
direct sense but as we go through this I
want to frame it for you up front his
supporters loved it his supporters loved
it before we go into the clips
understand that however you see Donald
Trump as a hopefully rational sensible
thinking person who watches or listens
to the David Pakman show
what you see in these upcoming clips his
followers loved and saw as strong Trump
unwilling to be bullied and pushed
around competent Trump dealing with
everything perfectly that's a really
scary reality that we have to come to
terms with let's get into it Donald
Trump often mentions the 1918 flu he
often calls it the 1917 flu this was a
pandemic from about a hundred years ago
it was late 1918 through early summer of
1919 it affected infected rather it's
believed about 500 million the death
rate could have been the death toll
could have been anywhere from 17 million
you hear 50 million you sometimes hear a
hundred million based on the numbers you
look at Trump wildly claims without
evidence that the 1917 flu ended World
War one prematurely check this out right
you remember the Spanish flu
so much has been written about it now of
course it's taught us everybody that
writes a book about the Spanish from
1917 it killed between a hundred and I
guess fifty to a hundred million people
it probably ended the First World War
because the soldiers were all getting
sick now this is not true it's simply
not true the war sort of formally ended
with the Treaty of Versailles
in June of 1919 but fighting had mostly
died down seven months prior to that
there's no question that there were
service members around the world
infected with the flu but this is a
crazy thing for Donald Trump to say no
pushback whatsoever from martha
maccallum and bret baier
not to defend them but almost everything
Trump said on this issue was false so
there was a sort of Gish Gallup effect
going on look that term up if you're not
familiar with it
Trump was asked a question about how he
was supposedly getting intelligence on
the virus really early and he ignored it
and Donald Trump claimed that he wasn't
told that the virus might be a thing
until January 23rd I'm gonna play the
clip for you now remember we had our
first case on January 20th that we know
of we now know it was obviously far
earlier because of when the first death
happened but there are two options here
when Trump says he was first told this
could be a thing On January 20 23rd
neither is good I'll tell them to you
after we watch the clip because I did
the right thing I saved hundreds of
thousands of lives ok she's asking me
the question about intelligence I have
the head of the intelligence agencies
here today and here's the exact thing
and we have it it's going to be released
tomorrow the next day but I released it
today on January 23rd I was told that
there could be a virus coming in but it
was of no real import in other words it
wasn't all we got to do something we got
to do something so understand Trump says
he was told January 23 the virus might
come in we had our first case three days
earlier okay we had our first case on
January 20th South Korea had its first
case right around the same time as we
did within hours of our first case they
by January 23rd were already developing
a test and setting up ways to contact
trace and isolate people and Trump is
now claiming he was first told this
could be coming in three days after the
first case now there's two options here
one is Trump is just lying and I believe
Trump is lying now his met his brain may
have turned to mayonnaise and he may not
recall that he was being briefed about
this in early January the
reports about briefings in December
there are now some reports which we have
not yet fully corroborated that suggests
in late November this was already being
discussed so Trump could just be lying
and saying I didn't even really hear
about this as a serious thing until
three days after the first case that is
probably a lie if it's true it's
outrageous that Trump was not seriously
warned until three days after the first
case it goes against every bit of
reporting we have I believe Trump is
lying or has completely lost his memory
neither is good continuing with this
disgusting townhall Donald Trump claims
that he has been treated that he he has
been treated worse than Abraham Lincoln
and hilariously the person asking the
question actually said why do you
sometimes ramble without asking
questions that are asked of you by the
press here is that part of Donald
Trump's answer the question I have is
presentation why do you use descriptive
words that could be classified as
bullying and why do not directly answer
the questions asked by the press but
instead speak of past successes and
general ramble the US I need you please
let go of those behaviors that are
turning people away from you please hold
on to your wonderful attributes that
make you our great leader and let go of
other characteristics that do not
surgery great I think I like that
question I'm not sure but I think I like
that question I appreciate it I
appreciate the prayers too very much
look I am greeted with a hostile press
the likes of which no president has ever
seen the closest would be that gentleman
right up there they always said Lincoln
nobody got treated worse than Lincoln I
believe I am treated worse now of course
Abraham Lincoln was assassinated okay
Trump is talking about being treated
worse by the press than Lincoln but
again
Trump's delusions delusions of grandeur
treated worse than anyone including
Lincoln because sometimes the press asks
real questions and he never answers them
and they have to ask again now on the
death toll this is really important and
it's actually tragic Donald Trump is
very casually
the goal posts for close to a month
Donald Trump has been saying we're gonna
have 60,000 deaths thanks to me
could have had 1.5 million we could have
had two point two million but thanks to
me our death toll is going to be only
sixty thousand that ship has sailed we
now are already at almost 70 thousand
deaths in the United States so Trump has
very smoothly talked about listen we
could lose eighty or ninety thousand and
that would be terrible
moving the goal posts take a look that's
one of the reasons we're successful
that's one of the review call losing
eighty or ninety thousand people
successful but it's one of the reasons
that were not at that high end of the
plane as opposed to the low end of that
number has changed mister president you
said it's going up I used to say 65,000
and now I'm saying eighty or ninety and
it goes up and it goes up rapidly but
it's still going to be no matter how you
look at it at the very lower end of the
plane if we did be shut down now this
was always the plan say some insanely
high number that would only happen if he
literally did nothing and then say he
gets credit for it being less understand
a couple of different things this 1.5
million two point two million
Trump for the first time now floating
two point five million that may have
been if he literally did nothing no
president could realistically do nothing
so it's an outrageous bar to set to even
compare to but the real dishonesty is
that in the last 48 hours
Trump has increased his expected death
toll by fifty percent from 60,000 to
90,000 and the way things are going it
could easily be a hundred thousand
before we know it but Trump is immune
from criticism because again without him
it would have been two million
he's now for the first time floated 2.5
million if he did nothing that's a
higher number than he's ever mentioned
before this is mere politics for Donald
Trump it's not lives and one just
strange moment during yesterday's Town
Hall was again it was a very hopped up
Trump who seemed to be crunching and
sweating and visibly on some he was
upper Trump I don't want to say what he
was on if anything but he was upper
Trump he said that he was asked for
Schwab's Schwab's by a governor
is just too funny we had one Governor
Inslee who's always wanting something
and frankly he didn't do a very good job
when nursing homes as far as I'm
concerned state of Washington and he
said we need swaps I said why don't you
get him yourself
but if you can't we'll get him so ok
swaps a totally lie riddled propaganda
event a few other notes donald trump
said joe biden wrote him a letter of
apology that's just not true trump once
again started talking about
hydroxychloroquine and told multiple
lies about its efficacy and trump
continues to say that china is paying
for tariffs I want to take a moment just
to explain that I need everybody in my
audience to understand this and I think
most of you do Trump still doesn't
understand how tariffs work Trump
continues to insist we're punishing
China by putting tariffs on them which
they are paying us and sometimes he says
it's like a tax on China please
understand that American companies play
the tariff pay the tariffs I know I've
said this before I have to keep
repeating it because Trump seems to
still not understand if China sells
steel for a thousand bucks a rod okay
doesn't matter whatever amount a
thousand bucks a ton and we put a tariff
on China China still sells that steel
for a thousand bucks a ton but if
there's a fifteen percent tariff on it
when an American company buys it the
American company pays China they're a
thousand bucks and they pay the
government a hundred and fifty more
dollars American companies pay the
tariffs now if you believe that this
trade war would work
China could be forced to lower their
price and accept the lower price because
of the tariffs that American companies
are paying it's not happening it's not
happening Trump still doesn't understand
how tariffs work we are seeing is the
active and willful dissemination of
weaponized propaganda but the saddest
thing is that his followers love it and
they see this as a strong performance we
have one option and it's to remove Trump
in November
hope you'll help me do that briefings
Donald Trump ran on having the most
transparent administration in history
part of transparency is having press
briefings Donald Trump's last press
secretary Stephanie Grisham had zero
that's not a typo zero press briefings
not a single press briefing during her
tenure the point of the press secretary
is to bridge the gap between what Trump
is thinking and doing and planning and
the press and Stephanie Grisham held
zero press briefings she was recently
replaced by Kayleigh Mackin an Eeyore
McKenna knee take your pick
she had her first press briefing on
Friday we covered it live as it was
happening and it was a house of horrors
I will spare you a lot of the absolutely
meaningless answers she gave which had
no substance but I want to focus on one
thing she was asked during the press
briefing will you pledge never to lie to
us never to lie to the press and she
said yes I will never lie to you and
then she lied her way through the entire
press briefing let's start with that
question coming from the the press corps
will you lie to us and she looked
absolutely dazed the entire press
conference one of the strangest ones
I've seen but here is her answer about
lying I will never lie to you you have
my word on that as to the timing of the
briefings we do plan to do them I pledge
not to lie to you and then she spends
the entire press briefing line let's
take a brief tour of the lies she
claimed for example that the Moller
report was a total exoneration of donald
trump at a lot of your papers I've seen
a whole lot of scant information about
Michael Flynn when there was a whole lot
of speculation about Russia Russia
Russia culminating in 40 million dollars
of taxpayer money being lost in the
complete and total exoneration of
President Trump thank you guys so much
this is an acute provable lie Robert
Muller actually said if we could have
exonerated
Trump on obstruction of justice we would
have said it so it is a direct lie that
the molar report was an exoneration of
Trump
McEnaney also said that the molar
investigation cost 40 million that's a
popular Trump is talking point even
Trump has said it the truth is the costs
of the investigation were 32 million but
it recovered according to one report 42
million it recovered according to
another report 46 million so the molar
report recovered more money than it cost
she also said not a single ventilate not
a single American has died for lack of a
ventilator Trump has been saying that
it's really hard to know if that's true
for sure
but we have reporting that multiple
people had to be placed on one
ventilator which you're not supposed to
do we know that a terminally ill person
had to be removed from a ventilator to
put someone with coronavirus on it we
know that some hospitals did have
rationing decisions to make about
ventilators so we certainly can't say
for sure that no one died due to a lack
of ventilators big lie on Michael Flynn
Donald Trump's convicted former national
security adviser Caylee Mackin Annie
said that there was a handwritten FBI
note that said we need to get Flynn to
lie and they are alleging that this
means that there was a sort of perjury
trap set up all this is is interrogators
planning an interrogation interrogators
already knew Flynn had lied and they
were trying to get the lies on the
record that's all it is they are trying
to make it out to be some smoking gun
and it's not now last thing on this what
the White House press corps should have
asked Caylee and they didn't ask her
about this is that she went on TV in
February and she said President Trump
isn't like Obama president Trump will
never let the coronavirus come to the
United States here are her words don't
take my word for it absolutely this
president will always put America first
he will always protect American citizens
we will not see diseases like the corona
virus come here we will not see
terrorism come here and isn't that
refreshing when contrasting it with the
awful presidency of President Obama
Kaleigh mackaninee thank you so much
good to see you thank you that's what
Kaylee Mac and Annie should be asked
about and I hope she will be Kaylee you
told us in February that Trump would
never allow coronavirus to come here
we now have 1.2 million cases and our
death rate is the 14th highest in the
world can you admit you were wrong about
Donald Trump that's the question that
should be asked
it wasn't hopefully we will see it asked
in the future make sure you're following
the David Pakman show on instagram at
david pakman show the david pakman show
at david pakman.com the number one
funding source for the David Pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world-famous
bonus show every single day just for
members as well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in and
day out you can sign up for membership
very very quickly at join pakman.com
that's join PA que ma n comm if the
normal prices strike you is high by all
means use the coupon code vote soon 18
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program today dr. Michael Shermer who's
the publisher of skeptic magazine and a
New York Times bestselling author his
latest book is giving the devil his due
reflections of a scientific humanist
it's so great to have you back on nice
to be back on David nice to see you
so these are strange times and I mean
just just to sort of open things up what
have the last couple of months revealed
to you if anything about humanity that
you maybe did not consider as deeply
before in terms of our ability to deal
with calamity about our leaders about
really anything I mean just where is
your mind right now
yeah I'd say first of all people for the
most part I've been pretty good about
social social isolation and and you know
staying down in one place you know
there's a few handful of protesters with
their Confederate flags or swastikas
and-and-and semi-automatic rifles that
people point to but that's that's pretty
rare I think most people particularly in
California where I matter are pretty
good on the negative side I'd say it's a
sign of how fragile and networked the
economy is how quickly things can kind
of unravel and there's no mystery about
it we know exactly why the economy has
collapsed and but it does show you to
what extent it it's all sort of propped
up by all of us
doing our thing you know just kind of a
collective action by individual action
and how what happens when everybody
stops even when they don't want to how
fast that can unravel although as Adam
Smith famously said there's a lot of
ruin in a nation so I don't think we're
on the brink of the the apocalypse or
anything like that but obviously we we
have to get back to work at some point
here in that the first probably bit by
June or July certainly by the end of the
summer before things really get pretty
serious in that regard just based on the
numbers I'd say I'm a little bit worried
this morning that
the death rate is not plummeted like I
thought it would when the testing went
up I thought what with mass testing the
denominator would go way up and
therefore the that the percentage of
death would go down to more like 1% but
it's still it like 5.8 percent this
morning in the United States and about 7
percent worldwide so it's possible more
testing will change that and get it back
down to something like a serious flu but
right at the at the moment it's it's not
just a bad flu it's way worse than that
so I think the social isolation thing
was the right move yeah and of course
when we look at the antibody tests we
have to assume at least from what we see
so far that the real case denominator is
certainly at least a couple of times
higher than than the real number of
cases but a lot of we really won't know
until later in terms of the in terms of
the protesters a little bit I've not
been giving it too much oxygen in terms
of the individuals I've been more just
thinking about the the public health
implications and the guidelines that are
being put out there you and I have
talked about these issues of free speech
and suppression of speech before you've
been critical of right and left for
suppressing speech is the entire thing
of these protests really even an issue
of free speech at all in your mind
because you very quickly see protesters
who say being told I can't be out
gathering and protesting violates my
constitutional right to assemble and to
ask for my grievances to be redressed
it's the government literally saying
don't speak like what is there something
there is that not really a concern here
I don't think it's really a concern
constitutionally or in the long run of
course you know the Constitution
guarantees your right to assemble and so
on but but if we want to think of it
just as a liberty issue you know the
freedom for you to swing your arm ends
at my nose
you know the harm principle applies here
that in this particular case you know
assembling in a large group without you
know social isolation or you know six
feet distance and masks and so on
does put other people at risk so while
you want your freedom III should be free
from your
contamination and so my freedoms
violated and and so we can we can talk
just freedom versus freedom rather than
just freedom versus security and that
and when you frame it that way I do
think this this is gonna pass most
pandemics do do wind down after a while
I think the most vulnerable will have
already you know suffered through within
say the next month or two I think and
whether we get a vaccine or not I think
we will get some kind of herd immunity
in the next year or so but the problem
is there's so much we don't know I mean
even though Qi he's not omniscient know
as much as I admire him nobody knows a
lot of these questions we just don't
know and that's of course where there's
a you know a vacuum of causal
explanation that's where all that goofy
ideas come in and in conspiracy theories
and alternative theories and alternative
medicine quackery cures and things like
that and they're all over the place I've
been writing about these and tweeting
about them and it's just pretty much
every couple hours is a new conspiracy
theory and even Trump yesterday was
talking about you know not that the
Chinese invented the virus in a lab it
very likely is a you know a bat virus
derivative from that web market but they
did they did do what totalitarian states
typically do which is be you know
dissemble and and be less than honest
and delay by weeks before they admit
what's going on much like Chernobyl in
the Soviet Union so this is China's
Chernobyl and I think they're gonna pay
the price for that probably with
sanctions from other nations again but
again we just there's so much we don't
know well this seems like ground zero
for so much of the work you've been
doing for a long time now in terms of
the importance of inquiry understand
having a basic science education knowing
how to think critically epistemological
basics where we we see I mean even with
the the lab thing as an example if this
was was if a mistake was made at a lab
in China and this was allowed to sort of
get out that does not in any way bear on
Donald Trump's competence or
incompetence in reacting right I mean
like in my misery South Korea and the
United States had their first cases
within hours of each other they dealt
with this come
lately differently whether it escaped
avaya a lab accidentally or not seems
wholly irrelevant to analyzing our
government's response that's right
totally irrelevant yes and you know
Trump's easy to criticize because he he
stumbles so many times but really it's
not fair because whatever he would have
done it was gonna be the wrong thing to
do in somebody's eyes half the country
size so you shut down too early and then
say in in early February then he would
have been accused to being an autocrat
using the pandemic as excused to grab
more power which some politicians have
been doing like in Turkey and Hungary in
Israel and of course already in China
and North Korea was already there so
Trump would have been lumped in with
those and then if you wait to if he
waits too long and then he you know he's
a genocide I'll you know maniac by
letting people die and you know so I
don't envy that job universal things
like for example South Korea immediately
for example developed a working test
while Trump said we don't want that test
I don't know that we need one yet we'll
make our own that failed South Korea
hired contact tracers right away huit
massachusetts now is looking to hire a
contact raiser there seems to be less
controversial things that weren't done
yeah that that's right I would agree
with that and in hindsight we can look
back at the different countries
responses and use those as natural
experiments sort of a comparative method
that we that social scientists used to
see well this country did that and these
were the results and so I know they're
not perfect like Sweden for example it's
a very different culture and more
homogeneous much smaller and so on so
they're they're keeping the economy open
you know is maybe not comparable to us
doing the same in America so you have to
be careful on that I'd say South Korea
is a pretty good model you know they
they are a democracy they have pretty
good civil rights pretty good record of
civil rights and and they seem to be
striking the right balance so far but
again we'll see when it comes to some of
the stuff you talked about so we've seen
everything from here's a silver liquid
you can drink to protect yourself we've
seen claims of this is less
deadly than the flu we've seen videos go
viral
of one or two doctors here or there who
will say hey nobody else is telling you
the truth about this I'll tell you the
truth we don't need lockdowns we don't
need any of this stuff
Bill Gates conspiracies regarding
vaccine like we've seen the full gamut
of it you know is this you've studied
this for so long is this something that
could be cut off with better education
in middle school is this a media based
problem what are the sources of having
this degree of disinformation spread
well the source of course the the
Internet and instant publishing and
everyone's their own publisher so
conspiracy theories can spread more
rapidly particularly in that vacuum of
causal explanation when we don't know so
this is kind of a perfect storm for
conspiracy theories I also like the 5g
one you know that sort of accidental
correlation of the rollout of 5g with
with the corona virus pandemic and again
people just glom on to whatever is
available and and you know 5g it's
invisible and spooky and powerful you
know Bill Gates he's he's powerful and
so I'm old enough to remember when Bill
Gates was trying to take over the world
in the 90s so you know these conspiracy
theories about him have been around for
a long time well I think new research
since 2016 since the 2016 election and
the stuff about the Russian hacking and
the manipulation of social media you
know by BOTS and so on it looks like it
had very little effect on the election
itself or on people's opinions that is
people were already fairly divided and
that those kind of social bubbles just
reinforce what you already believe but
fixing the incorrect facts that are
posted there is not likely to change
somebody's mind because that's not why
they're there in the first place as the
line is that you know if you believe
that Hillary is running a pedophile ring
out of a pizzeria my correcting your
error and believing that isn't going to
change your opinion of Hillary as you
already don't like Hillary so I think
these kinds of conspiracy theories don't
ineffective in terms of the masses of
people and what they're likely to do I
think most people will do what dr. Fuji
we should do who you know even though
there'll be a handful of the people that
try the the what was that fish tank
liquid yes that had hydroxychloroquine
in it as a antifungal drug for fish you
know that guy died you know that's so
rare you know and in a population of you
know 340 million people you know just
point zero zero zero one percent doing
something crazy is is enough to fill the
evening news but but but not an
existential concern so how has the
pandemic if it all shifted what you
think the priorities for humans should
be over the next five or ten years in
the sense that you've written about
where where is the future of humanity in
terms of space and you've talked about
Mars you've talked about your shift on
your perspective on guns of course you
talk about free speech and the limits of
government has any of what's happened
shifted your view notably on what the
priorities should be going forward yeah
well I do think a lot of cultural norms
are going to shift the handshake is
probably gone for years and it probably
won't come back because once those
cultural norms are pretty fluid and and
they're not all that binding perhaps
even hugs will be gone but you know we
can make it up you know with the yoga
bow or the Japanese bow or something
like that and and people get used to
that I do think we're probably for a
long time be more sensitive to
hand-washing and and the cleanliness of
our environment both both at home and in
public places like restaurants stadiums
things like that
and that's probably a good thing I could
I could project the number of
communicable diseases going down just
from those kinds of protective
prophylactic measures that we probably
should be doing anyway I think we've all
gotten kind of lacks about that I was at
that Vancouver TED talk TED Conference
when Bill Gates gave that speech about
then you know the next big pat debbik
and this is what he's worried about and
all of us were sitting there going yeah
yeah yeah yeah we've heard this before
you know not that we thought he was
wrong but just that like you know yeah I
mean people say this all the time and
and and even if it happens you know
won't be that bad and and and here it is
you know I I think probably we should
have been in hindsight you know doing
more and now we will and I think that
helps I think probably psychologically
will more of us will be appreciative of
friendships social relationships and
contacts are our immediate social group
and who we hang out with just because so
many people are kind of feeling bad
missing that social contact that you
know zoom and and online social media
just doesn't give you and I know you
know I'm in California Gavin Newsom
close some of the beaches but not all
the beaches where I'm at in Santa
Barbara the rates very low here so the
beaches are still open it's a huge
relief for people just to get out and
walk around and see other people even if
they're six feet away you know that that
human contact act just you know within
you know physical contact not not
touching but just visually seeing people
I think does matter I think that's
probably gonna longest term effects so
we'll be healthier you know there's
there was a study done just before the
Carano virus hit that the average human
body temperature of 98 98 what is at
98.6 degrees right it has actually been
going down over the last century or so
probably because the number of
inflammatory diseases that causes body
temperature to go up have been going
down just because we're getting better
medically at treating these things so I
can actually see body temperatures going
down less inflammatory diseases which is
good for long-term health and and maybe
people particularly Americans and the
obesity problem this might scare people
into getting a handle on their their
diets and exercise and and more and more
people are exercising now that's a good
thing so even if the whole coronavirus
thing was was exaggerated we never had
social isolate and workout and eat so
well
well exercise and eating well is a good
thing to do anyway so that's not such a
bad thing no question about that
we've been speaking with dr. Michael
Shermer publisher of skeptic magazine
New York Times bestselling author the
latest book which were linking to is
giving the devil his due reflections of
a scientific view
yes Michel always so great to have you
on nice to see either you stay safe
there the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as $1 per month plus you can get the
daily bonus show world-famous at this
point and the daily commercial free TV
show by making those pledges at
patreon.com slash david pakman show this
is audience supported media we depend on
the support of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on TV or even
listen on the radio patreon.com slash
david pakman show the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
so we're starting to see sort of a new
divide in the fight against
coronavirus earlier you have these metro
areas with larger population densities
more flights directly to China you
started seeing those areas have more
cases pretty early so New York City
certainly at the top of that list Boston
would be another example as well and
you've got places that are less
connected to the global economy having
fewer cases early on we are now starting
to see divergence where the numbers are
starting to improve pretty dramatically
in some of these early hotspots in terms
of a reduction in cases and a reduction
in deaths and reduction in serious cases
and people in icy use but we have a new
wave of cases in places that have been
insisting all along hey I don't know
that we need to close we don't have any
cases and very quickly they are getting
many many more cases and they still seem
to not understand how viral growth works
now let's look at one example and that's
Mississippi Republican governor Tate
Reeves
was insisting for weeks Mississippi can
open we can open Mississippi
everything's great here and indeed he
decided to go ahead and open businesses
the cases spiked and he is cancelling
that plan he's calling it a pause but
okay I mean eventually businesses will
open the plan to open now has been
cancelled Friday Mississippi at about
400 new cases and 20 new deaths and they
have changed their plans governor Tate
Reeves should actually be applauded for
doing this we shouldn't make fun of the
fact that his initial plan was wrong he
should be praised because he's actually
looking at the data and changing the
plan because when you look at other
places that have started to open and
it's still in some cases we don't even
see the full effect yet places like
Florida are quickly finding more and
more new cases despite still having
pretty low levels of testing Virginia is
now finding close to a thousand new
cases a day Texas is finding close to a
thousand new cases a day and they're
only testing a third or a quarter of
what places like Massachusetts and Rhode
Island and New York are testing if
you're only testing 14,000 people a day
and you're finding a thousand new cases
a day those numbers are going to go up
even faster as you start to test more
Indiana is another place that supposedly
had no problem they were all set to go
one of the top growth rates by
percentage now over the weekend Ohio
becoming a hot spot Georgia may be the
hot spot by the end of the week as
governor Kemp there has just blown the
doors wide open Georgia has nearly
30,000 cases now I believe that if we
had stayed as close to fully shutdown as
possible just two more weeks everywhere
we would have been in a good position to
have more testing by then and to be able
to start easing restrictions and
guidelines but now a lot of these states
are going to fall very very far back
here in Massachusetts Republican
governor Charlie Baker extended the stay
at home order it was supposed to end
today may for Charlene Baker has
extended it by two weeks to May 18th and
we've seen cases level off we've got
about a three percent new case rate per
day and it hasn't been climbing we've
seen a net decrease in hospitalizations
over the last week deaths have dropped
from close to 200 a day to about 100 a
day still a lot still tragic but that's
the direction you want to see things
going my instinct is that in another 14
days if Massachusetts keeps doing this
the numbers are going to look
dramatically better the opposite seems
to be happening in many southern states
now I want to praise Mississippi they
had a plan we thought it was the wrong
plan many of us did they looked at the
data and they changed the plan we can
focus on it was a bad plan to start with
and it was a bad plan to start with but
lots of states have bad plans and many
of them aren't changing the plans as the
data changes Georgia Texas and Florida
are examples at least governor Tate
Reeves realized the plan doesn't match
the data and we have to change our plan
Mississippi is a place with the worst
health care in the country according to
u.s. News 50th out of 50 they can't risk
having their system overwhelmed which
would lead to a very high death rate he
changed his mind and that's great let's
see what happens in these
they're places as cases spike Texas and
Georgia we will be following closely all
week many states now also have armed
protesters demanding that they be
reopened
protesters showing up yelling at cops
typically not wearing face masks very
very ugly stuff FoxNews propagandist
Tucker Carlson was instantly destroyed
on live TV
after parroting the falsehood that young
children don't spread coronavirus which
is a very dangerous and irresponsible
thing to say Tucker Carlson interviewed
Fox News dr. mark Siegel mark Segal has
certainly had some cringe-worthy moments
on fox news over the years but credit to
mark Siegel he called out Trump for the
bleach injection Fiasco and he instantly
calls out Tucker Carlson for this wild
claim about kids and coronavirus check
it out latest science there is new
evidence that young children do not
spread the corona virus not what we
thought dr. mark Siegel is a fox medical
contributor an NYU Langone professor
doctor thanks for coming on tonight
Tucker I want to cut through the news
and get to the science of this which is
that seventy eight studies at the United
Kingdom show that children especially
under the age of ten are not very likely
to get covered 19 or to spread it but
one of the authors of that study says
he's being a little bit misinterpreted
and the Centers for Disease Control has
said that 1 to 2 percent of the cases
looking at 150,000 cases were children
under the age of 18 that the real truth
here is and a China study showed that 90
percent of children have asymptomatic
cases so Tucker they appear to have a
protein in the lungs that protects them
from severe disease and almost all of
the children who get this or either
asymptomatic or have mild cases but it
is not true that children don't get it
and it is not true that they can't
spread it just much less likely than
adults
the look on Tucker's face if you were
watching a look that says this is going
horribly wrong that's worth Tucker's
weight in gold young children do not
spread coronavirus mark Siegel
immediately says actually children do
spread it Tucker Carlson says hmm this
is the type of stuff that
when the disinformation spreads it leads
to infections people are just mixing up
different claims so let's look at them
are children less likely to get a
symptomatic case of the virus yes that's
what the science currently says when
children do get it is their chance of
dying from it lower than adults
absolutely what the science says right
now but children can spread it even when
they have it without symptoms this is
one of the reasons that schools had to
be closed because one parent gets it
then a kid has it then ten kids have it
and they bring it home to their parents
what Tucker Carlson is saying is just
not true there seems to be no
coronavirus rumor that someone on Fox
News is not willing to spread Tucker was
just complaining that shut downs and
stay at home orders were not decided
with science and then he casually says
kids can't spread the virus when of
course they can and it's particularly
important to understand that the most
dangerous spreaders can be those without
symptoms because the kids have no reason
to think that they're sick and then they
become vast spreaders there's a study
that finds actually that kids zero to
six have a very similar viral load as
those 12 to 19 and may be spreading the
disease just as effectively as high
schoolers now what is certainly true is
that if an adult gets the virus and you
contact trace there are probably fewer
kids they've been in touch with unless
you have kids or you work with children
most of your contacts are going to be
adults maybe that's where something got
mixed up but good for dr. Siegel to
immediately call out this nonsense from
Tucker Carlson we have a voicemail
number that number is two one nine two
David P I am called out by Troy York
using one of his many pseudonyms for not
wearing a mask take a listen to this
nope hold on a second I guess I hit the
wrong button here we go hey impact man
woody Underwood from Indianapolis
Indiana sure hey I've listened to your
video about my I'm not wearing a mask
and what's really funny is that in your
video you are now wearing a mask so how
often you wear masks and why aren't you
wearing one for your stupid podcast and
no one really watches except maybe BOTS
right and your your gay friends in
Boston who brutally homophobic I think
that you ought to take a couple masks
put some mayonnaise on it or in some
butter yeah this guy calls into the show
eight to ten times a week by the way so
listen I'm wearing a mask when I go into
any grocery store or post office or
whatever I don't wear one on the show
because I'm at home I'm just sitting in
my house so it would be really weird to
wear a mask we have updates on the bonus
show about Kim jong-un we will talk
about a women's soccer lawsuit losing an
attempt at equal pay and we will also
talk about a court weighing in as to
whether mass gathering bans should apply
to churches I believe that they should
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join packing.com or
a patron at patreon.com slash david
packard show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try bling kissed for free and save
25% off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash david pakman i've
also included the link right underneath
this video